Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and yesterday
in my Arrow video I asked you all to submit
questions.
So I picked 10 to answer in this video with
one bonus questions.
We also just found out when Merlyn is coming
back.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Q&A videos a couple times a week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
My countdown series starts next wednesday
too.
So before we answer questions there’s just
been a huge news update.
Malcolm Merlyn will be back in Episode 22,
based on the description, Thea is going to
run into him or he’ll run into her.
We can talk more about that in the comments,
but until now I almost didn’t think he’d
show up until the finale.
So we’ll have to wait and see what happens
before we can guess what Merlyn will do in
the finale.
Whether he’ll fight with Team Arrow against
Slade or do something totally different.
And now, to questions!
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Question 1 - Drew Cole asks Do you thin laurel
will tell Oliver she knows he's the arrow
or will she just keep it to herself?
I think she’ll listen to Quentyn and just
keep it to herself.
When she went to hug him you could tell she
wanted to support him.
If she had told him he’d probably be too
distracted worrying about her to fight Slade.
Add to that all the extra problems with Queen
Industries, Thea and Roy right now and you
arrive at Hug Time.
The best thing she could have done for him
in that moment, was just give him a hug.
And she did, which is why it was such a good
moment.
I think her relationship with Team Arrow will
be like Quentyn’s in Season 3, except she’ll
know who they are, but they won’t know that
she knows.
She’ll be a stealth team Arrow member.
So stealth that Oliver won’t even know she’s
on the team.
Question 2 - Baby Maker asks why does Oliver
keep calling Thea speedy?
Speedy is his affectionate little sister nickname
for her.
He uses it whenever he wants to show her he
cares about her.
It’s one of the ways he shows brotherly
affection.
It’s not meant to imply she’s going to
become the Speedy character from the comic
books at some point.
I know a lot of you are wondering if she’ll
become the Artemis character at some point
too.
I think we’ll have to wait till after this
season to guess where her character is going.
Especially her relationship with Merlyn.
Although I think that situation will be like
Oliver’s Father choosing his family over
Isabel Rochev.
Thea will just be forced to choose between
Merlyn and her family.
I don’t think he’s going to train her
or anything like that.
If she ever did become a Team Arrow member,
it would be way more fun to watch Oliver train
her like he’s training Roy.
Just imagine her slapping endless bowls of
water.
Question 3 - Sharmilan (no avatar) asks What
about the bandage on Roy's arm?
Could be to do with the clone that CADMUS
makes?
So you’re thinking like a Superman Superboy
situation.
That would be interesting, but I think they’d
only clone a meta human.
Like someone with actual superpowers.
And Roy is just juiced up on Mirakuru.
The bandages are probably just where they
attached the machine to his veins.
I think if there end up being any cloning
storylines in the future, especially with
STAR Labs involved, they’ll use them as
Flash crossover opportunities.
So it would have to be some big epic thing.
That seems like a little too complicated for
the show to tackle in it’s first season,
The Flash that is, but it could always happen
in the future.
Question 4 - Legitimate Gamer asks How did
Slade get inside the Arrow Cave if he didn’t
have one of those super keys like the one
Felicity stole off The Clock King?
He’s ex-special forces and the mirakuru
has made him almost indestructible.
But even before he became a super soldier
he had experience in breaking into places.
Mostly to kill people I imagine, like he almost
did to Team Arrow.
The only reason he broke in was to spank them
for setting his operation back.
That’s why he had to raid STAR Labs for
that device.
I loved that Felicity stole that key technology
off the Clock King though.
It just reminds us that she knows an opportunity
when she sees one.
Like window shopping for cool toys.
Question 5 - Green Quiver asks How do you
think Danielle panabaker will become Killer
Frost?﻿
This is where things get really interesting,
because she totally seems like one of the
good guys based on her relationship with Felicity
and Cisco.
Since she’s such a big character from the
comics, yes eventually she’ll become a version
of Killer Frost.
But I think on the show, she’s going to
start out being good.
The real question is what her character arc
is going to be.
Like good person researcher, then she gets
in a horrible accident and turns evil.
Or is she just a normal person that gets corrupted
by Zoom or someone else.
There’s also the possiblity that they could
be messing with the character and just call
her “Frost” like the way Green Arrow became
just “The Arrow” on the show.
I think that’s more likely.
When you use the name Killer Frost, you kind
of telegraph what a character’s story will
be and I think they want it to be more of
a mystery for us as fans.
No matter what happens, I think she’ll be
a normal human for most of the first season.
I think The Flash and Zoom will be the only
real super powered people for a while.
I think any Rogues that pop up will just be
using tech, like Arthur Light’s tech they
had locked up in storage.
As opposed to being full on meta-humans.
They did say there would eventually be more
superpowered people on the show though.
Just not right away.
Question 6 - Fsniper asks Do you think team
arrow will use the cure for Slade and use
it on Roy?
I think we should ask if they’re going to
have to pick which one to use it on, like
they’ll have to either cure Slade or Roy,
but not both.
Logically you’d think they’d be able to
synthesize a ton of it.
And now that we know there really is a cure,
I think that’s how Oliver will get rid of
all the new Super Soldiers.
So let’s just say they’ll have a bunch
of it, enough to do Roy and Slade.
I definitely think they’ll cure Roy, Colton
Haynes isn’t leaving the show.
He’s still got to finish his Jedi Training
so he can become Arsenal.
As for Slade, I think everyone even the writers
want him to be able to continue on as the
Deathstroke character, but a slightly less
insane version.
So I think they’ll end up using the cure
on him too.
They won’t kill him and he’ll just dissapear
the same way Merlyn did after season 1.
They’ll just leave it open for him to return
in the future.
I don’t think he’ll be around a lot in
Season 3 though.
They’ll make room for new villains to come
in.
Question 7 - Danielle Mawdesley (no avatar)
asks do you think Laurel will confront Sara
about being The Canary before the end of the
season?
I think we’ll get a Spider-Man 2 situation,
the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man 2.
Remember when he was saving Mary Jane from
Doctor Octopus and his mask came off and she
saw it was him and they had that moment.
I think they’ll do a reverse version of
that.
It will be more from Sara’s perspective,
since Laurel already knows it’s her.
They’ll have a sister moment when Sara gets
unmasked in battle.
I’m expecting something like that to happen
in the finale.
But until then, I think Laurel will treat
her just like she’s treating Oliver.
Question 8 - Harsh asks Do you think Oliver
will become Mayor of the city like in the
comics?
Only if Moira is the one to die this season.
There’s still a funeral scene in episode
21, we don’t know who it’s a funeral for,
it could be Slade doing a fake funeral for
Isabel Rochev.
So that he can surprise them with Ravager
later.
Otherwise I think they’ll give that Mayor
storyline to Moira like they are right now.
I don’t think she’s the most interesting
character, and yes I do think Oliver as mayor
would be more interesting.
But we’ll have to just wait and see.
Question 9 - Lizbeth (no avatar) asks Producers
have hinted that Felicity's backstory is going
to be a big thing for season 3 but could we
possibly get a cliff hanger about this in
the finale?
Definitely, the major arc for next season
always gets teed up by what happens during
the finale.
So whatever the resolution of the Slade storyline
is, it will be related to Felicity’s backstory.
Maybe in just a minor way, but keep your eyes
peeled for special Felicity stuff in episode
23.
I’m really hoping that her Father is the
season 3 villain and is someone connected
to HIVE.
Question 10 - Schmoley (no avatar) asks With
a Booster Gold tv series supposedly in the
works, do you think we'll see a cameo in Flash
or Arrow?﻿ (prob flash)
Booster Gold always spent more time in the
Flash comics, so if he shows up anywhere it
would be there.
That episode could also be an Arrow Crossover,
just to guarantee the show a bigger audience,
but I don’t think we’ll see him until
Season 2.
I don’t think they’ll try to complicate
The Flash storyline in season 1 by throwing
in a ton of new characters right away.
But Geoff Johns has been trying to get a Booster
Gold show going for a long time, so you’ll
see him eventually.
Bonus Question - Vaughan O’Hara asks Do
you think we will see any more Flash characters
this season?
I think the only Flash Crossover we’ll see
the rest of the season is one, for the mirakuru
cure from STAR Labs and two Felicity actually
going to visit Barry.
I don’t think they’ll show that, they’ll
just have a scene where she says she’s going
to Central City to visit him.
So thanks so much for submitting questions
guys, I always like being able to answer you
directly in a video.
Like I said, next week I’ll start posting
bonus Arrow Videos each Wednesday morning
counting down to the finale.
Be sure to subscribe to get them if you just
finding me for the first time.
Right now click here for my review of the
episode and click here for my finale predictions.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!